THIS MAN GOT TIRED OF VAGRANTS
AND GATHERED UP THEIR BELONGINGS
AND THREW THEM IN THE TRASH.
THAT MAN HAS BEEN CHARGED WITH
SECOND DEGREE ROBBERY AND THE
AREA REMAINS A HAVEN FOR NEEDLES
AND TRASH AS IT HAS FOR YEARS.
IF I SHOWED UP ON YOUR FRONT
LAWN WITH A SLEEPING BAG AND A
CASE OF VODKA, AND SORT OF MOVED
IN TO STAY, WHICH I MAY DO,
WOULD YOU BE ARRESTED FOR TRYING
TO MAKE ME LEAVE?
>> WELL, I WOULD BE DUMB I COULD
YOU AND BE HAPPY TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH YOU AND HOPE
WE COULD HAVE DINNER SOMETIME.
BUT EVEN MORE TO THE POINT, THE
PERSON WHO THROUGH THE
BELONGINGS IN THIS CASE OF A
HOMELESS MAN INTO THE LAKE AND
INSTALL SOMEBODY ELSE'S
CELL PHONE, THAT PERSON WOULD BE
PROSECUTED WHETHER THE PERSON
THEY DID THAT TOO WAS HOMELESS
OR NOT.
HOWEVER AS TO THE DEEPER
SOLUTION, TOMORROW THE CITY OF
OAKLAND WILL BE DEBATING OUR
BUDGET AND I WILL BE FIGHTING
FOR BETTER SOLUTIONS TO
HOMELESSNESS.
WE NEED TO HELP PEOPLE LIVE IN
SITUATIONS OTHER THAN OUR
STREETS AND SIDEWALKS, EVEN
THOUGH WHILE I ABSOLUTELY
CONDEMN THIS ASSAULT AND CONDEMN
IT NO MATTER WHO IT WAS DONE TO.
>> Tucker: IT JUST SEEMS LIKE
THE CARDS ARE KIND OF STACKED
AGAINST NORMAL PEOPLE.
MARRIED PEOPLE WITH KIDS AND IT
JOBS, KIND OF LIKE THE A
BACKBONE OF AMERICA.
THEY ARE HAVING A TOUGHER TIME
LIVING IN THE STATE, SO THEY ARE
GETTING ARRESTED AS YOU KNOW.
PEOPLE ARE GETTING ARRESTED FOR
TAKING HOMELESS THAT TREE IS UP
TRASH OFF OF THE PROPERTY BUT
THEY ARE GETTING ARRESTED FOR IN
PUBLIC?
WHAT'S BEHIND THAT?
>> CERTAINLY IF PEOPLE WANT TO
VOLUNTEER TO CLEAN UP OUR LAKES,
OR PUBLIC WAYS, WE HAVE LOTS OF
OPPORTUNITIES FOR VOLUNTEERISM.
THIS WAS NOT AN ACT OF CLEANING
UP THE LAKE.
IN STEALING SOMEONE'S BELONGINGS
IN STEALING SOMEONE'S BELONGING
BELONGINGS.
>> Tucker: BUT WAIT A SECOND,
WE HAVE A READY-MADE GROUP OF
PEOPLE, MANY OF THEM YOUNG WITH
TONS OF TIME ON THEIR HANDS AND
RECALL THEM, FOR THE HOMELESS.
WHY DON'T THEY CLEAN UP THEIR?
WHY ARE THEY THE ONES LITTERING,
WHY ARE THEY CLEANING UP?
>> IT'S NOT THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
LITTERING, AND 85% OF THE
ILLEGAL DUMPING IS COMING FROM A
VARIETY OF ILLEGAL SOURCES.
SO THE ILLEGAL DUMPING THAT WE
ARE FIGHTING TO CRACK DOWN ON
IS --
>> Tucker: SO YOU ARE GETTING
TO THE CAUSE -- OKAY.
>> AS WELL AS PROVIDING BETTER
PLACES FOR THE HOMELESS TO BE.
IN OTHER WORDS IT'S NOT ENOUGH
TO SAY WHERE WE DON'T WANT
PEOPLE TO GO, WE NEED TO PROVIDE
THE PLACES AND I'M SITING FOR US
TO USE PUBLIC LANDS, CHURCHES TO
VOLUNTEER FOR USE OF THEIR SITES
WHERE THEY CAN GET ASSISTANCE
AND THEY CAN GET MATCHED WITH
SOCIAL SERVICES AND IT TURNED
THEIR LIVES AROUND WHILE LIVING
IN PLACES BETTER THAN THE
SIDEWALK.
>> Tucker: CHURCHES HAVE A LOT
OF SPACE IN CALIFORNIA IN WHICH
NOBODY GOES.
LET ME ASK YOU ONE -- >> IF YOU
DIDN'T WANT TO COME BUT I'D BE
HAPPY TO REMIND US ALL THAT WE
ARE JUDGED BY HOW WE TREAT
PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: I AGREE WITH THAT,
WHY IS IT THAT CALIFORNIA'S
SO-CALLED HOMELESS PROBLEM IS
OFTEN BLAMED ON HOUSING COSTS.
AND IN MOST CITIES THEY ARE
REALLY HIGH BECAUSE OF THE ONLY
RICH PEOPLE THAT LIVE THERE.
BUT TOKYO HAS EVEN HIGHER
HOUSING PRICES AND NO HOMELESS
PROBLEM.
WHAT DOES TOKYO KNOW THAT
OAKLAND AND SAN FRANCISCO DON'T
KNOW.
>> MOST OTHER DEMOCRACIES IN THE
WORLD DEVOTE A LARGER SHARE OF
THE PUBLIC FUNDED TO HELPING THE
HOMELESS TO PROVIDING SOCIAL
SERVICES.
>> THEY DON'T HAVE A TON OF
BROKEN FAMILIES AND DRUG
PROBLEMS IN JAPAN.
AND THE FACT THAT A LOT OF
PEOPLE ARE LIVING OUTSIDE ON
HEROIN?
>> WE ACTUALLY HAVE A VERY SAD
SITUATION OF FAMILIES LIVING
OUTSIDE.
WE HAVE PEOPLE LIVING ON THE
STREETS WHO GET UP AND GO TO
WORK EVERY DAY AND COME BACK.
HOUSING IS SO SCARCE AND SO
EXPENSIVE.
AND I WILL BE FIGHTING FOR US TO
DO MORE.
>> HAVE YOU THOUGHT ABOUT THE
TOKYO THING?
BECAUSE THEY DON'T SPEND MORE
MONEY THAN YOU DO ON THE
HOMELESS.
MAYBE THERE IS A SOLUTION THERE,
AND I DON'T KNOW IF WE WILL
SOLVE IT ON THE SHOW BECAUSE WE
ARE ALMOST OUT OF TIME BUT HAVE
YOU THOUGHT ABOUT THAT?
>> MOST OF THE COUNTRIES HAVE
UNIVERSAL HEALTH CARE.
PEOPLE DON'T GET PUSHED INTO
DIRE STRAITS BECAUSE OF THE